-So, you have sold
tens of millions of books,
but I did not realize this --
that when "The Kite Runner"
came out,
you were still working
as an internist.
-I was, indeed.
-So you would have patients
come and see you.
Were they familiar?
Did they know at this point
that you had written that book?
-Well, they were finding out,
then, eventually,
it became a health hazard
because I had 20 minutes
to manage their heart failure,
their thyroid, their diabetes,
and I was spending
like 15 minutes of it
discussing plot points
of "The Kite Runner"...
[ Light laughter ]
...and signing books
for Uncle Joe.
And after a while, I was like,
"This is not good
for you, for sure."
It's probably not good for me,
either,"
So then I was like, "Yeah,
probably should step away."
-So you stepped away
and made the decision
to be a full-time novelist.
-Yes.
-Something that is obviously
a little easier to do
when you are already the author
of a very successful book.
How did your family react?
How were they when you told them
about this career change?
-Skeptical.
-Uh-huh.
Even after "The Kite Runner"?
-Oh, well after
"The Kite Runner."
When I told my parents
that I was thinking
about stepping away
from medicine
and writing full time,
my mom was --
diplomatically, she goes,
"Are you sure?"
I said,
"Yeah, I think we're okay."
She said,
"You know, I went to Costco,
and they didn't have
'The Kite Runner.'"
[ Laughter ]
"So you may not be --
may not be as popular
as you think you are."
[ Light laughter ]
And thankfully, when I published
"A Thousand Splendid Suns,"
she walked into the room
with a copy,
and she goes,
"Guess where I got this."
[ Laughter ]
I was like,
"Whoo-hoo! I've arrived."
[ Applause ]
-That is wonderful.
[ Applause continues ]
So, this is obviously --
this book covers a very sad,
a very serious topic.
This was inspired
by the photo of Alan Kurdi,
who was a young boy
who was trying to escape Syria
and washed ashore --
his dead body washed ashore.
That was the photo
that inspired this book.
What was it about seeing
that that made you think,
"This is something
I want to explore,
something I want
to write about"?
-Well, look, I'm a dad.
I have two kids.
When I saw that photograph,
I was just bludgeoned,
like millions of people
around the world.
And part of the power
of that photograph
is that Alan is lying facedown,
and you can't
quite see his face.
So it's very easy to project
the face of your own children,
the people that you love,
upon -- on that photograph.
And so, I wrote "Sea Prayer"
to not only help keep
his memory alive
but, also, to remind all of us
the moral outrage we all felt,
the indignation
we felt collectively, globally,
when we saw that photograph,
which was such a brutal
and poignant symbol
of not only the Syrian War,
but the plight of millions
of refugees around the world.
And so, this is meant to be
a tribute not only to him,
but to, also,
the thousands of families
who've been cornered into making
that same kind of decision.
-And I should say all of
the money from this book
is going to
the UN Refugee Agency.
-Yeah.
-We were talking backstage.
You were born in Afghanistan.
You came to this country
38 years ago today.
-Today, yeah.
-And your family...
[ Cheers and applause ]
You settled in San Jose, yes?
-Yes, yeah.
-You know, one of the things
that get lost is,
I feel like,
when we hear "refugee,"
all we know
about their biography
is they escaped there
to come here,
and we lose a lot of their --
the individuality that,
obviously, every refugee has.
How -- How does it --
How do you feel
about the way
we talk about refugees,
and was that the case
when your family came here?
Did you lose a part of you that
you left behind in Afghanistan?
-Well, the experience
of being a refugee
is -- is certainly a loss
of your land, your community,
your home,
all the things
you're familiar with.
But we tend to talk, I think,
about refugees
in very unhelpful ways,
as sort of this monolithic
community of needy people.
The fact is that refugees
in this country
are essential strands
of the American story.
You know, America has a very
long history with refugees.
In this country,
refugees are teachers.
They're advocates.
They're professors.
They're entrepreneurs.
Refugee-owned businesses
pay billions of dollars
in taxes every year
that goes
towards fire departments
and police departments
and schools and infrastructures,
all the things that we,
collectively, as Americans
benefit from and enjoy.
And so, I, as a refugee
and a person who has resettled,
actually happen to think
that America is, in part,
better and stronger and richer
because of refugees
and not despite them.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Another thing it seems
like we always --
we focus on, you know,
what can we do for refugees?
And we focus a lot on --
on a number.
We should -- We should allow in
this many refugees a year
versus this many refugees
a year.
For those who actually get here,
and from your experience,
what is something
that you can do
if there are refugees
in your community?
What is a helpful thing that --
that refugees can use?
-So much you can do,
even a small thing.
You know, being a refugee
in a new country
is disorienting,
it's terribly confusing,
and I say that
from personal experience.
So if there are refugees in your
community, reach out to them.
Maybe they need help
with their English.
with applying for a job
or making
a doctor's appointment,
or applying for
a driver's license.
You know, show them how to use
the public transportation
system.
You know, if there
are refugee kids in your school,
talk to your kids and say,
you know,
"Go up
and make friends with them.
Ask questions.
Learn about their culture.
You know,
help them with homework.
If they're being bullied,
stand up for them."
You know, every little thing
that you do counts
and every small acts
of friendship and solidarity
is appreciated and remembered.
-Well, thank you so much
for sharing that
on your anniversary
of coming here.
[ Applause ]
-Thank you.
-We're certainly lucky
that you came,
and thank you so much
for writing this book
and all the work you do.
I really appreciate it.
-Thank you.